It's an act of tremendous cowardice, in my opinion, um,
for people not to realize that even in times of a pandemic, uh,
we still have to have our basic freedoms,
the freedom for if you are an individual.
And you think that COVID-19 is the bubonic plague.
You should have the freedom to be able to decide,
to stay at home and lock yourself in a basement in order, you know,
seamless and Instacart, if that's what you want to do.
But you should also allow me to have the freedom to open my business and to say,
you'd like to come into my business. Um, you know, I'd love to host you here.
[Inaudible].
I'm Dave Rubin, and this is the Rubin report.
I originally interviewed Candace Owens on March 12th to discuss her new book
blackout. But as we recorded news of COVID related,
lockdowns began and suddenly the news cycle totally shifted. Now,
six months later,
we're picking up the conversation and then releasing the original conversation
unedited along with the new pickup we're doing right now,
most guests would never allow an interview to sit for so long.
But if I can say one thing about Candace Owens,
it's that she's a woman of her words, Candice,
we shot that interview. It seems like a lifetime ago,
but it was March 12th.
And it basically was the day that the lockdowns were beginning.
And the second we stepped out of the studio, your assistant, my whole team,
everyone's telling us we're freaking out. You guys had to get out of LA,
but you are a woman true to your word even now, six months later.
Cause you were like, ah, I don't think this is anything. This is nonsense.
They're trying to take Trump out. And from everything I know of you since then,
you, you have consistently put that message out there. Um, so first off,
how are you haven't seen in a while? How are you doing?
I'm doing well? I think it's also important that I break the story here.
That on that day, uh, the morning I woke up at my hotel,
I had an allergic reaction to a feathered pillows lease was scratchy and
I had a cold and I came in and Dave and his husband did not believe that I had
had an allergic reaction and they thought I was COVID-19.
And just that you had an allergic reaction, you came in,
you were coughing and sneezing. The news is breaking all over the world.
And, and you were telling us that you had blood,
that you were coughing blood earlier in the morning, and then you're like, Oh,
you don't mind if I work from your house all day, do you, and what did I do?
What does a real friend do? You did? And we even fed you.
Yes, but that is what feather pillows do to me.
I have the strangest allergy with feathered pillows.
And if I sleep on what I wake up and I will literally be coughing blood,
but the timing I will give you credit,
it was just bad timing with COVID-19 stuff freaking out. So.
How bad would,
would Vox love it if Candace Owens was patient zero on
COVID-19. I mean, come on.
She would have loved it so much.
They would have loved it. All right. So listen, I said to you,
before we did this,
that I wanted to do a pickup with you because it does feel like a totally
different world in just six months, it feels so different,
but we are going to air that interview. Totally unedited just as it was. Um,
but I thought it was worth talking for another half hour or so.
Just about what has gone on for the last six months,
if any of that has changed your, your feelings on anything or anything else.
So first off you, you are in DC, uh,
you've become a creature of the swamp somehow. Um,
what's life like in DC, how has COVID effected you? And, and, you know,
you're pretty outspoken about this stuff, but are you,
are you okay with any level of lockdowns, any level of masks, anything.
I'm not okay with any of it? You know,
I think it's very easy when people are scared, um,
to convince them to give up their freedoms. And we saw that. I mean,
people hardcore, conservative suddenly like, yes,
we should all be locked down for businesses to close. Um,
and it's an act of tremendous cowardice in my opinion, um,
for people not to realize that even in times of a pandemic, uh,
we still have to have our basic freedoms,
the freedom for if you are an individual.
And you think that COVID-19 is the bubonic plague.
You should have the freedom to be able to decide to stay at home and lock
yourself in a basement in order, you know, seamless and Instacart,
if that's what you want to do.
But you should also allow me to have the freedom to open my business and to say,
if you'd like to come into my business, um, you know, I'd love to host you here.
Um, that's that freedom doesn't go away because of a pandemic.
And I think people sort of lost the thread on that because they were so
terrified. You know,
now people have obviously shifted their opinions and where people are on my
side.
I tend to take a very bold and strong opinion early on when people are unsure.
Um,
but to me it was the entire coronavirus narrative was just too perfect and too
timely, uh, in an election cycle, uh, we have to force,
we have to shut down the economy.
We had to put everybody on welfare and give them stimulus checks. And you know,
nobody, nobody can leave their home.
So they have to rely on the mainstream media narrative because they can't go out
and have experiences with their friends that would make them say, you know what?
Maybe, um,
it's not as scary as it is as I've been out to a party a few times and I haven't
gotten the illness, so I never trusted it. Uh,
of course I think coronavirus is real. Um,
what I was questioning was the idea that it was some plague,
like thing that was going to take us all out if we stepped outside of our door.
And I really thought it was about mail-in voting from, from day one.
Yeah. And by the way, you were taking it from both sides,
you kind of touch on this because you were,
you were given it to conservatives who were all about a lockdown suddenly and,
and you know, government overreach, let's say. And then I saw like this,
the usual suspects, the lefty blue check people,
because you dared to go to whole foods without a mask.
And then there were several blue check people that blood is on your hands.
Candice, how many people have you killed? How many.
Apparently times for going to whole foods, they were like, well,
how could you possibly say, she goes to whole foods every day and I'm like,
look, I can't go anywhere because you shut down.
All of my events happen to live near a whole foods.
And I like to look at what they have at the meat counter every day. Um, so,
you know, I, you know, at the time during COVID lockdowns,
I was early in my pregnancy. So, um, I am an asthmatic,
so I have pre-existing conditions. And I ended up deciding to travel the world,
uh, because I was that convinced of how untrue narrative was.
And I was shocked to discover the second you step outside of America,
you realize we're the only ones playing the crazy game. And I was in England,
there were no mass mandates. I went to Croatia.
They have no idea that there's even a Krone coronavirus going on.
The kids are running around really no mask, no social distancing. Um, so it,
it just felt to me, especially when I got home,
because I had those experiences and it was really being manufactured for
Americans.
All right.
So I want to ask a question that I think cuts to the heart of the Candace Owens
that I know, but is also the public Candice owns,
which is those first few days when everyone was freaking out,
when everyone is really freaking out and you just took that position of this is
BS, this is nonsense, all of that stuff. What is it about you I've,
I've asked you some version of this before,
because I even remember seeing your tweets right at the beginning.
And I was kinda like, Oh, Candace, like,
you might really be stepping in it right now. You know,
if a week later it turns out that, you know,
half of us have this thing or everyone over 60 is dead,
but what is it about you that you just do it?
You just get the thought and you're just like, I'm rolling.
You know, I think I have very good gut instinct. Um, I, I, I have,
I just always really trusted my gut, um, on certain things. And,
and like I said, it was, it was too perfect.
And usually if something seems too perfect, it's because it's too perfect. Um,
and it was just also all of the media at the death.
Ticker was very strange to me like that. We've never done that before. I mean,
if, if CNN MSNBC did a death ticker for every time, there was a car accident,
you'd be terrified to get in your car.
So I was already seeing that there was a psychological element that the media
was playing because there was,
it was just very bizarre to see a death ticker for anything, of course,
you're way more likely to get into your car and get into an accident in LA,
but they would never do that. Um, and,
and so I really felt that it was just too easy for them to get into the minds of
so many people. And I'm so crazy about not being brainwashed. And, um, it just,
none of it made sense to me at all. It just, it just from start to finish,
never thought it made any sense.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.